the New York Times attacks Mount
Rushmore just like I said they would the
black lives matter organization finally
comes under fire and China ends Hong
Kong's freedom I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the bench Bureau show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn why
haven't you gotten a VPN yet go to it
right now visit Express at VPN comm
slash Ben okay so we are approaching
July 4th and as I discussed yesterday on
the program July 4th is well worth
celebrating Independence Day is well
worth celebrating because it celebrates
the fundamental principles espoused by
the United States Eddins at its
inception not completely fulfilled for
huge swaths of Americans but fulfilled
gradually over time we talked yesterday
on the program specifically about July
4th and what it meant the principles of
inalienable rights pre-existing
government the idea of equality before
the law inequality in those rights and
the notion of a government that was
created to protect those god-given
rights that is worthy of celebration on
July 4th well the alternative
perspective which is that America is not
worth celebrating
has obviously gained a foothold in the
United States a massive foothold in the
United States but it's not just that
there's a certain vitriol that comes
along with this perspective on America
that is truly incredible
unruhe read you a little bit from a
piece by Jamila Lemieux and I normally
don't read from slate because slate is
obviously a left-wing publication it's
an openly partisan publication so
there's not much to discover there but
there's a mindset that is worthy of
evaluation here that I think is exposed
in this care and feeding column right
the advice columnist over at Slade's so
the title of this column is my kids dad
is a Trumper should I criticize him
openly or keep it civil I've been trying
to instill my liberal values without
disparaging their father but these times
call for more okay so the basic premise
of this particular advice question is
I'm divorced my husband is a Donald
Trump supporter my new husband and I are
liberal my kids come over and they have
heard one perspective from their dad and
now I want to give them the other
perspective should I be polite about it
so the column says here's the question I
have three young kids 10 nine and six
for my adore due to life circumstances
they live mostly with their dad for the
school year
I see them often they live with me and
their stepdad during the summer some
breaks my husband and I are very liberal
my kids dad is very conservative like
Trump supporter
conservative in my time with the kids I
talk politics a lot and do my best
friends still my values while also being
very careful not to say anything bad
about their dad or his beliefs for
example if they mentioned something
their dad told them I focus on saying
what I disagree with and why rather than
saying what I really think such as that
belief is immoral but I can tell that
their dad isn't exactly reciprocating
they've said some things that make me
pretty sure he's just vilifying
democrats and liberals every chance he
gets
they're young so nuance is lost on them
I feel like I'm playing the long game by
being the one who never disparages the
other side but given what the other side
is doing these days I'm wondering if I
should play hardball too how do I handle
this politics and parenting
here's the answer dear politics and
parenting the Democratic Party could
write a book about what happens when you
try to keep to the high road and be the
one who never disparages the other side
spoiler alert
it ends with over a hundred thousand
Americans dead with Kovan and millions
more who might be considered brain-dead
to paraphrase a man who waged a wholly
unnecessary war on Iraq and may end up
becoming one of your kids idols if you
don't act fast the highroad really ain't
high if it means negotiating with
terrorists you feel me do your best to
emphasize the other things that are good
about your acts and the importance of
loving him in spite of his values be
careful to differentiate between bad
politics and bad people which is bullsh
is what she writes which is bull bleep
but your children can grow up and decide
to discard their father for being a
deplorable when they are old enough to
realize the two cannot be separated and
that the idea that they can is a myth
that white folks have been spreading to
the detriment of everyone for far too
long this isn't a here's why daddy sucks
thing it's
here's why conservative values are evil
you need to make the moral depravity and
xenophobia of the right wing as
painstakingly clear to your kids as you
possibly can whenever you can this is
more than hardball this is a battle for
the souls of your children and I say do
anything and everything you can do to
win it if that includes being the parent
who gives the best gifts and and lets
them stay up the latest and eat the most
junk food so be it if your children
become maggots and porters you will
never be able to live with yourself and
most of us won't be able to live with
you either this is war
Godspeed comrade now the reason I read
that is because I think that that lies
at the heart of a lot of the radical
left that we are watching these days a
perspective that the America that was
based on the Declaration of Independence
a perspective on American history rooted
in the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution of the United States a
belief that natural rights pre-exists
government a belief that what we should
be seeking is equality before the law
not equal outcome after
the law is is twisted and changed that
is perceived as as legitimately evil
legitimately evil by a vast swath of
human beings in the United States that
if you disagree with this that you that
America's bad terrible horrible no good
very bad place of racists terrible place
filled with bigotry and that all the
systems of America are at root corrupt
then that means that you are morally
depraved your xenophobic in fact it
justifies giving your children childhood
diabetes and sleep deprivation in order
to prevent them from believing the kinds
of things that would force them to vote
for Donald Trump or lead them to vote
for somebody like Donald Trump now I
know a lot of Trump supporters I know
tons and tons of Trump supporters I know
tons of conservatives people who voted
for George W Bush twice or voted for
Mitt Romney voted for John McCain and
weren't even in love with Trump just
pulled the trigger or didn't pull the
trigger for him I know tons of
conservatives I do not know a
conservative fits this description as a
human being I do not know a conservative
fits this description but this is the
myth the mythical conservative that has
been created in the minds of so many
people on the left because again if you
believe that America is a true evil and
your obligation becomes quote/unquote
resistance your obligation becomes
tearing down the systems and if that
means he's telling us task of separating
children from their parents teaching
their children that their parents are
bad human beings if it means that you
have to tell kids that their parents are
bad for believing a different thing
about tax rates or believing that
America isn't a true evil then you do it
because after all this is war Megan and
this is I think just saying the quiet
part out loud for a lot of folks I don't
think this represents the vast majority
of liberals in the country I think there
are still liberals is why I always
separate on the show between liberals
and leftists there are liberals in the
country we still believe in open
conversation and who don't attribute
evil morality to people that they
disagree with but there are an awful lot
of people on the left in the hard left
is gaining not just a football but maybe
a dominant position in American politics
today I believe exactly this this is war
in war all is justified all is fair and
if that means that you have to castigate
the father of your children as a bit a
person you chose to have children with
as a terrible human being
then you do it okay that is not can
anyone think that this is gonna be a
livable country with that sort of
perspective
does anyone think there's gonna be a
livable country that part sort of
perspective and that is the perspective
on the one side are all the good morally
decent righteous people and on the other
side is innate evil on the other side
are all the deplorable
all the terrible truly bad people on
planet earth now number one this is such
a self flattering perspective for a lot
of folks on the hard left and the so
flattering perspective comes from the
idea again that while they have been
shaped by evil systems they stand apart
from the systems they're sort of
citizens apart they're better than
everyone else and more intelligent and
everyone else that's the only way you
can come to this conclusion because in
in the view of these folks they hold a
higher morality such a high morality is
a great thread today on Twitter from
Robert McCrum
the professor the McCormack professor /
Princeton University in ethics Robert
George it's a really terrific thread
about how people tend to perceive their
own morality and it is it is correct he
tweets out today I sometimes ask
students what their position on slavery
would have been had they been white and
living in the South before abolition
guess what they all would have been
abolitionists they all would have
bravely spoken out against slavery and
worked tirelessly against it of course
this is nonsense only the tiniest
fraction of them or any of us what was
spoken up against slavery or lifted a
finger to free the slaves most of them
and us would have gone along many would
have supported the slave system and
happily benefited from it so I respond
by saying that I will credit their
claims if they can show evidence of the
following and in leading their lives
today
if stood up for the rights of unpopular
victims of injustice who's very humanity
is denied and where they have done so
knowing one it would make them unpopular
with their peers - that would be loathed
and ridiculed by powerful influential
individuals and institutions in our
society 3 it would be abandoned by many
of their friends 4 they would be called
nasty names and 5 it would risk being
denied valuable professional
opportunities as a result of their moral
witness in short my challenge is to show
where they have at risk to themselves
and their futures stood up for a cause
that is unpopular in elite sectors of
our culture today and the answer of
course is virtually no one does that
now that is very rare because human
beings are sinful and one of the great
flaws of leftist thinking is the belief
that innate human sin disappears as long
as you change the system the human
beings aren't sinful human beings aren't
bad that you are a better person you
have been changed by your own thought
process on politics beyond the capacity
for human sin which of course puts you
on the side of the angels and all of
your opponents on the side of the devil
this is a religious philosophy at this
point that piece and slate it's a good
indicator of religious philosophy about
politics that is absolutely
unsustainable on any logical level
absolutely unsustainable okay we're
gonna get to how that sort of attitude
has now infused our major institutions
of our society right so it shows these
these folks aren't the resistance anyone
anymore
okay the hard left is not the resistance
the hard left is the culture the
counterculture is conservative at this
point the dominating heights of our
institutional culture are dominated by
the hard left our media are dominated by
the hard left dominated Hollywood is
dominated by the hard left corporate
boards are dominated by either people
who are willing to cave to the hard left
or members of the hard left the culture
is no longer with conservatives it is
with the hard left the culture has
shifted beneath the feet of
conservatives who are so worried about
electing Republicans that they forgot
that the way that hearts and minds
change is through the cultural system
and so all the institutions that
conservatives naturally dominate have
fallen away churches have lost
constituents or indeed cave2 leftist
values corporations where you would
think businesses where you would think
that conservatives who dominate have
caved to the outside cultural pressure
to perform leftist walk signaling but
what we are watching right now is the
same thing that happened in the
universities in the 1960s the student
protestors became the professors in the
administrators the commanding heights of
the culture have now been taken over by
the hard left I'm gonna show you
examples of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
sleep is a little bit hard to come by
these days the news is incredibly
terrifying and depressing all at once
plus if you got kids they're waking you
up at all hours of the night I know I
have several of them helix sleep this is
what you need they've got a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete and
match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or firm
bed with helix there is no more guessing
and no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm slash Ben
take their two minutes sleep quiz it
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a ten year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights at
risk-free and we can pick it up
for you if you don't love it but indeed
you will helix is offering up to $200
off all mattress orders for our
listeners and up to $200 off at helix
sleep comm at /bin that's helix sleep
comm slash been htl IX SLE EP comm slash
man the mattress is great I know it's
great because I have one my wife and I
customized the mattress just for us it
is fantastic
you love sleeping on it helix sleep comm
slash been use that slash pen you get up
to $200 off and it it's guaranteed this
thing is gonna be fantastic you're gonna
love it
and so the the moral gap that now exists
in our society in which an entire sector
of society that sneers at the entire
other side as immoral as bad human
beings like I thought for a long time
this is a real differentiating factor
everything about this for probably at
this point decades the differentiating
factor between right and left is that
the right tends to think the left is
wrong and the left tends to think the
right is evil the entire culture is now
dominated by people who think that the
right is full-out evil and this means
censorship it means censorship CNN a
supposedly free speech outlet right
they're whining and bitching every
single day about the fact that President
Trump is means them oh it's a threat to
the press oh he's gonna shut down the
press when he's done nothing except
raised their ratings hey CNN put out a
headline yesterday about the advertiser
boycotts of facebook over hate speech
their headline was here's a list of
companies who have none who have not
cancelled Facebook yet
hey the yet is the key word there that's
an activist headline that's an activist
headline and that's what these media
outlets become they're activists they're
activists of the hard work left who
believe that everything that must be
crushed in their path sort of utopian
system that generates better human
beings so everyone can be like done
everybody can be part of the board all
you have to do is simply give away your
autonomy and your ability to think essay
as a as an individual human being and
you have to buy into the narrative that
your own individual problems in
everybody's individual problems
everybody's individual sins that is not
a result of an eight human nature or
individual choice that is a result of
the evils of the system and so every
statue has to come down so those statues
are part of the system Mount Rushmore
should come now I'm old enough to
remember when I said that Mount Rushmore
would be attacked within the next week
there'd be people who were calling for
the destruction of Mount Rushmore and
Governor Christie gnome of South Dakota
she tweeted back not on my watch well
now she's gonna get a chance to prove it
the New York Times has an
front-page article today at least on
their website called hell Mount Rushmore
became Mount Rushmore
the entire article is about how about
Rushmore his evil Mount Rushmore was
built on land that belonged to the
Lakota tribe and sculpted by man who had
strong bonds with the Ku Klux Klan is a
tweet from the New York Times it
features the faces of two US presidents
who are slaveholders ah so it's time to
blow it up let me just note the New York
Times is built on land appropriated from
Native American peoples for a handful of
beads that's the New York Times building
they're free to hand it back anytime
they please the New York Times was
complicit in the Soviet regime to the
point where one of their own reporters
Walter Durant you want to peel it
surprise for covering from for the
Holodomor the the destruction of
Ukrainian peasantry in the great
collectivization of the early 1930s the
New York Times is a bleep heap and it
has been for a very very long time so
when do they win what are they gonna
knock down their building and hand it
back to the Native American tribes from
once it was taken what are they gonna do
it the answer is never of course but
they are they're great people over the
New York Times and they don't have to
think about such things all the statutes
have to be knocked down because after
all those statues are emblems of a
system a system before which there was
nothing but Rousseau in state of nature
in which everyone lived in peace and
harmony which is absolutely historic
nonsense by the way worth noting that
Mount Rushmore I love that they say
Mount Rushmore was built on land that
belongs to the Lakota tribe in Lakota
tribe gained that land in 1775 by
expropriating it from another tribe
which in turn historically speaking had
expropriated it from another tribe so it
turns out that conquest human
immiseration has been the constant
throughout all of human history
virtually every culture but because we
have now created the world's best people
the most morally the most morally wise
people in the history of humanity they
can stand atop the pile and they can say
that they are different and they know
that they are products of an evil
civilization a particularly evil
civilization over in Columbus Ohio
they've now taken down a 22 foot solid
statue of Christopher Columbus after the
city's mayor for conference come down by
the way this is happening in in in
Columbus Ohio in remove the Columbus
statue in Columbus Ohio which I guess I
guess they will call it flavor t'en
which is exciting is and remove this
statue
why not because they're so concerned
with the predations how Christopher
Columbus as a human being I don't see
any FDR statues coming down these days
FDR was responsible for the imprisonment
of a hundred thousand japanese-americans
hey butBut Christopher Columbus has to
come down why specifically because of
what he was put up for see this is the
thing this is the thing statues are
generally erected not Confederate
statues which are a bit of a different
story which I'll explain in a second
statues that are coming down now the
ones that are really controversial the
Columbus statues the Washington statues
the Thomas Jefferson statues those
statues the Lincoln statutes those are
erected in tributes to be good things
that sprang from the actions of the men
who are being honored with the statue
when you erect a statue of Christopher
Columbus it is not a it is not a statue
of a say it is not an icon people don't
go to that statue and worship right
there's a difference people go to many
different places on earth where there
are statues of saints and pictures of
saints and they worship there the
iconography as a long history in human
worship erecting a statue of Christopher
Columbus nobody was walking by that
statue and bowing their head in prayer
and saying pray on my behalf Christopher
come on no one was doing that because
he's not a religious figure Christopher
Columbus was an important figure because
he brought Western civilization to the
Western Hemisphere this is for
civilization a very good thing that does
not mean that it came without brutality
or that it came without cost because
brutality and cost are endemic to human
nature but to dis own Western
civilization which is really what you're
trying to do when you tear down a statue
of Columbus because let's all be frank
about this the people who are tearing
down the statues of Columbus it's not
because they're reading the journals of
16th century Spanish monks criticizing
criticizing Christopher Columbus that is
not why they're doing it's not reading G
las casas and then going you know
Christopher it turns out he's a bad guy
that's not what's happening here what's
happening is they don't like the West
and therefore they are trying to tear
down the symbols of the West including
Christopher Columbus
it's why the Boston Art Commission just
voted unanimously not like five three
they voted unanimously to remove the
emancipation memorial and Park Square on
Tuesday night the emancipation memorial
in Boston is a direct it's a direct copy
of the Emancipation Memorial in
Washington DC a statute designed by a
Charleston Massachusetts native named
Thomas ball and dedicated in eighteen at
seventy-six paid for by freed slaves and
in spoken at the inauguration of by
Frederick Douglass this is removed
why was
not because of why they say it was
removed so the people who are who are
doing this they say that this was
removed because people aren't
uncomfortable with the statue and it's
reductive representation of the black
man's role in the abolitionist movement
is according to mayor mayor Marty Walsh
that is not wise being removed the
reason it's being removed because
anybody who perceives that America had a
role in ending slavery even in America
or than America did a good thing in
ending slavery or that Abraham Lincoln
did a good humane thing and ending
slavery is not ripping into the system
Lincoln because he was president is a
symptom of an evil system it doesn't
matter that he fought within the system
to end the system of slavery the system
itself is the evil and so if you are a
if you're an advocate for the system if
you believe that the system actually is
good and then we strayed from founding
principles well then that makes you bad
too you are now part of the system
you're just as evil as that dad that
they were talking about in Slate
Magazine you're the bad right this is
the this is the great fight you want to
talk about a cultural war that is
happening right now in the country this
is the cultural war that is happening in
the country a post American America
versus an America that does root itself
in Americanism as we approached July 4th
that's what this battle is all about I'm
mentioning I've a book coming out July
21st is all about this how to destroy
America in three easy steps
the destruction of America's culture
history and philosophy those things are
continuing the pace that is what we are
watching right now tearing down America
about our ears now other countries have
experienced post post European Europe
right there is something that was a
major crisis for Europe and led to a
massive migration of people who are not
necessarily instilled with European
values and is led from Menace culture
clash waves of crime serious living
problems in places in Europe for sure
hey a country that cannot stand up for
its fundamental principles or refuses to
stand up for its fundamental principles
puts itself at risk to take an example
in Israel this was a big issue in Israel
there was sort of a post as IANA speriod
in Israel where a bunch of people
decided that Israel well maybe we should
we've had it should Israel been a thing
that we established maybe we shouldn't
have established it after all
and the and the voters in Israel started
electing very left-wing governments that
apologized for Israel's existence the
result was that Israel's enemies were
emboldened Israel's enemies embolden
then proceeded to kill a lot of Israelis
which resulted in a snapback where
Raley's recognized oh wait maybe there's
a reason we exist and so now virtually
the entire Israeli populace is
center-right the same thing is happening
right now in the United States we are
living through a period of post
Americanism America where a huge where
generations of Americans have been
taught is a sign of virtue to disown
your Americanism you are a citizen of
the world you're a citizen of goodness
above and beyond any culture that
created you and you have to tell your
sign of strength is as Shelby Steele
says dissociation if you just if you
dissociate from the American system that
is a sign that you are powerful now
understand that that is not a risk that
is not a risky scenario for you you get
rewarded for that in the culture this is
why I say it's important to note the
counterculture is now the culture there
is no risk in saying any of this there's
no if you go out there in public and you
say things like you know Mount Rushmore
was expropriated Native American land so
you know what if people say it should be
torn now and should think about it there
is no risk in the culture for you to say
that if you say right now in the culture
Mount Rushmore is a signifier of the
greatness of many American presidents
because America is indeed a great
country and the American flag stands for
freedom there is a shot you will be
fired from your job at many corporations
these days I'm getting notes from people
all over the country right now and if
you simply say yes I believe that black
lives matter but the police are by and
large virtuous people attempting to keep
law in order and if they disappear
people die you could get fired for that
okay we know what the poles of power
have shifted in the culture Republicans
focus so much on winning the political
people always wonder in the Republican
Party I get this question all the time
why is it Republicans keep winning
elections and yet the culture keeps
shifting to the left cuz you're focusing
on the wrong battle this is not the
correct battle you can win as many
elections as you want if the ground
keeps shifting under your feet
you're just shifting the deck chairs on
the Titanic that's all you're doing you
shore up the hole at the bottom of the
Titanic
that means re-educating yourself about
the United States and not buying into
the lie that America is uniquely evil
another another example of people
portraying America as uniquely evil as
part of the broader black lives matter
rubric which again it's amazing a
linguistic trick of taking black lives
matter that phrase which of course is in
arguable of course black lives matter
and then piling on top of it in the in
the words of Vinnie from my cousin
Vinnie is there any more bleep we can
pile on top of this right is there any
more any more bleep we can pile on top
of the basic truth the black lives
matter
because we're gonna pile on top bit Neil
marxism we're gonna pile on top of it
how America sucks we're gonna pile on
top of it slavery reparations we're just
gonna pile everything on top of it do
you fund the police you start from this
you start from this one very easy points
of agreement and then boom you just blow
it up beyond all recognition we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that when you go to
the bathroom I hope presumably you close
the door because your privacy is your
business wouldn't want random passers-by
taking a peek why would you want people
to take a peek at your internet activity
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and not
closing at the door inappropriate for
you and not great for everyone else did
you know the Internet service providers
like Comcast Verizon they know every
single website you visit what's worse
they can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giant's will use this
data target you expressvpn puts a stop
to this it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
Internet so your online activity can't
be seen by anyone I use Express VPN on
all my devices works on everything
phones laptops routers everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi could be protected
even if they don't have expressvpn if
you put it on your router the best part
is using expressvpn it's as easy as
closing that door just fire up the app
click one button or now protected by the
way lots people after your credit card
information these days it's not a great
time to lose your credit card
information to hackers basically it
never is go check out expressive VPN
right now go to expressvpn calm slash
Ben today when you use that exclusive
link expr ESS VPN comm slash Ben you get
an extra three months for free that's
expressive VPN calm slash Ben Express
VPN calm slash then okay so more
examples of the of the cultural
dominance of the perspective that
America is evil and that you're good if
you dissociate from America long-long
feature article in The New York Times
magazine called America's enduring taste
system our founding ideals promised
liberty and equality for all our reality
is an enduring racial hierarchy that has
persisted for centuries
hey so again the idea is that our
founding ideals they're a lie they were
always a lie and remain a lie nothing
has changed and this article is just
another example of the bizarre notion
that nothing has changed over time
you'll find a hallmark of these articles
which I've read on the air over and over
again is be taking of a bad a horrible
horrible situation in 1890 and then just
fast-forwarding to 2020 and going
nothing has changed it's something
energy better
in the documentary the 13th she'll talk
about slavery and then show immediately
fast formula and then Michael Brown it's
like whoa a few things happen between
slavery and Michael Brown you might want
to like review your history like that
much that much in order to be semi
honest but the point of course is not to
be honest the point is to give yourself
the feeling of virtue is why you see so
many white woke liberals jumping on
board with this nonsense to give
yourself the feeling of self-righteous
virtue because you have dissociated you
have now dissociated from America as
this article likens America to home
owners who inherited a house on a piece
of land that is beautiful on the outside
but whose soil is unstable loam and rock
heaving and contracting over generations
cracks patch but the deeper ruptures
waved away for decades centuries even
okay the deeper ruptures waves away for
decades centuries even really because it
seems to me that a lot of those ruptures
have been repaired and I say a lot of
those ruptures I mean 600,000 Americans
died in the Civil War I mean we had a
civil rights movement and a civil rights
act that completely rewrote the
constitutional bargain of the United
States and allowed government to do
things it had never done before and
should and frankly run way beyond what
the Constitution would generally allow
in order to rectify these ruptures but
the idea is nothing has changed this
columnist says many people may rightly
say I had nothing to do with how all
this started I have nothing to do with
the sins of the past my ancestors never
attacked indigenous people never owned
slaves and yes now one of us was here
when this house was built our immediate
ancestors may have had nothing to do
with it but here we are
the current occupants of a property with
stress cracks and bowed walls and
fissures in the foundation where the
heirs to whatever is right or wrong with
it we did not erect the uneven of
pillars or joists but they are ours to
deal with now okay this this entire
metaphor is entirely wrong the reason
the metaphor is wrong is because
whatever inequalities we can address
today because we don't have time
machines if you invent a time machine
I'm happy to go back to the past and we
can talk about alleviating problems in
the past but we don't have a time
machine so the question is what can we
do today to alleviate the systems that
are that are causing inequality and I'm
not hearing a lot of answers other than
people simply shouting at the moon that
the systems themselves are bad and when
you say okay you know what I grew
through on some of these police
brutality stuff see here's the thing
Republicans keep granting the premise
they'll say things like I'll agree with
you on the policy sure let's what sure
why not and then the goalposts keep
moving because guess what this has
nothing to do with policy it has
things with policy the United States has
spent tens of trillions of dollars on
anti-poverty programs
last I checked me I'm sorry
move sent five trillion dollars in the
war on poverty was last statistic I
checked it may be a lot higher now given
all of the late spending but at least
five trillion dollars spent in the war
on poverty okay that that is a lot of
money completely restructuring the
federal-state bargain in the process
that is a that is a major move the
notion that structural inequalities have
not been tackled at any level the notion
that we have not changed law and systems
is insane again the premise of this
piece is that we haven't changed
anything underlying we haven't shored up
the foundations we haven't changed the
foundations except that we have except
that we have this article says like
other old houses America has an unseen
skeleton its cased system which is a
central to its operation as are the
studs and joists that we cannot see in
the physical buildings we call home
taste is the infrastructure of our
divisions it is the architecture of
human hierarchy the subconscious code of
instructions from maintaining in our
case a 400 year old social order there
it is there it is right the entire
American social order is built on sexism
racism bigotry homophobia it must be
torn down at certain point the house
can't be supported you just have to tear
down the house and build a new house
because that's what you would do I mean
the metaphor is the house right the
metaphor is a house that is built on
unstable foundations that means you got
to raise it the best that the most
incredible ignorant insane part of this
piece throughout human history three
cased systems have stood out the
ling'ring millenniums long cased system
of india a tragically accelerated
chilling and officially vanquished case
system of Nazi Germany and the
shape-shifting unspoken race-based case
pyramid in the United States really
those are the three that stand out the
u.s. Nazi Germany and India where they
have actual untouchables there's another
case systems that you can think of other
than in virtually every civilization on
planet Earth I think other than
virtually all of human history we're
case existed this is this is insane it's
patently insane again that does not
excuse a prior cases but again the case
that does not exist
in the United States that case that does
not exist in any formalized fashion all
of humans sin cannot be healed by simply
changing the system's but even if it
could the United States has changed its
system radically
since 1964 to pretend otherwise is
historically ignorant or deliberately
dishonest and I think we all know that
it may be a little bit of both in a
second we're gonna get to suppose it
changes to the system that would fix
this but of course it's not about
changing the system it's about the
narrative is about a feeling of
self-righteousness it's about being part
of the post America America the post
American America the post American
ideals America the post July 4th America
that is the goal here Aaron gets him
more of this in just and the entire I
mean it some of the people who are
pressing this it's truly incredible
we'll get to that in just one second
first hiring can be difficult but if
you're a company that's currently trying
to hire you face new difficulties from
safely reopening your doors to finding
the right person for a specialized role
we're all trying to get back to work
right now you need a company that's
gonna help you find the best job or help
you find the best employee if you're an
employer you need to turn the Zipp
recruiter housing wire can relate they
needed an ambitious reporter to cover
news stories on the US mortgage and
housing markets so they want to zip
recruiter zip recruiters smart matching
technology finds people with the right
experience for your job in fact four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter at a quality candidate within
the first day that's how housing were
found Alexandra Roja now he's heading to
never imagined she could get a reporter
job in the midst of kovat 19 because
hiring was frozen so she created a
profile on zip recruiter and zip broker
matched her to housing wire reporters
job because her degree and writing
skills were really good fit for the role
and she got hired and we use a recruiter
here at the Daily wire it's why all of
our employees know that a moment's
notice they could be replaced with
somebody more skilled at their job zip
recruiter can help you make your
business better or help you find the job
you've been looking for
see how zip require a zip recruiter can
help you hire try it now for free at zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter dot-com slash daily wear
go check them out right now okay so and
the the effect this is why the press has
been four completely useless
solutions because any solution shows up
the system any solution shows up the
system so thing about this from a
political analog there are a lot of
people on the Left who believe that
anything that goes right in America is
bad for the country because in the end
it benefits from and there are a lot of
people right now who believe that if the
economy were to recover that would be
very bad for the country long term or
even midterm because it would benefit
Trump and you might get reelected which
would do more long-term damage there's a
whole perspective about America says
that if the Americans
is bad and evil and anything that is
good about the American system is
actually bad because that is upholding a
system that promulgates bad anything
that is good
we can't even acknowledge the good
America does because that might lead
people to be to be complacent about
these evil evil systems and so we're not
going to fix any of the problems so
here's the thing most people kind of
have an idea on how to fix some of the
inequalities that exist in American life
and most people kind of figure you know
what if people are going to bad schools
you know we should do we should fix the
schools you know what's one way to fix
the schools give people vouchers and
school choice
but nobody wants to pursue that most
people agree if we're gonna talk about
police brutality we should have more
transparent data we should think about
qualified immunity right most people
know and and how we how we change that
slightly right most people if you get to
specifics you can find agreement but the
point of our modern politics is not to
find agreements is to exacerbate
disagreements and that is why you see
the Democrats focused in not on getting
75 percent of what they want in a police
reform bill that the Republicans put
forward instead Democrats are very
excited to do a few things right they're
excited to for example push forward a
house resolution that would set up a
committee to investigate slavery
reparations which is not going to happen
right it's not a policy that is going to
take place and frankly any race
discriminatory policy is probably
unconstitutional in the United States
right now but this is what Democrats are
pushing says Sheila jackson-lee who is a
representative out of out of Texas Texas
18th district Sheila jackson-lee
yesterday she suggested that America
needs to pay reparations which of course
is about how America is deeply
anatomically evil we are 155 years
removed from slavery in the United
States and we are now almost six decades
removed from the Civil Rights Act of
1964 and Sheila jackson-lee says that
America needs to pay reparations race
reparations make no mistake here she is
explaining why she's pushing forward
this House Resolution which again is not
designed to do anything it's designed to
simply push the message that America is
endemically bad this 13 member
Commission established by the federal
government answers the question that is
not the individual act of holding slaves
it is the government sanction that
denied African Americans their equality
and as well the government's
responsibility with this 13 member
Commission to design the responses to
the continued death murder and
inequities in our community this is
America's responsibility to pay the
American government's responsibility to
pay her debt okay so it's America's
responsibility because America has never
has never rectified its ins America's
endemically evil and nothing has changed
hey can I just point something out about
Sheila jackson-lee Sheila jackson-lee
she's not to send it from American
slaves Sheila jackson-lee would not be
eligible for reparations if we actually
attach reparations to American slavery
right if we did it based on race she'd
be eligible but both her parents were
immigrants from Jamaica
she graduated from Jamaica High School
in Queens she earned a BA in political
science from Yale University in 1972 and
a JD from the University of Virginia law
school okay that does not sound like a
wildly unprivileged difficult life it
doesn't that doesn't mean she hasn't
overcome obstacles I am sure she has I'm
sure she has because most people do but
this is not somebody who is kept down by
the American system she's a 13 term
Congress person a 13 term Congress
person who is the who is the child of
immigrants from another country right
the notion that she's standing there
talking about the endemic evils of the
United States and that we need to pay
reparations on the basis of race what
that really is about is it's not about
solving any of the problems it's not
it's not about problem solving at this
point it's not even close to about
problem solving by the way even
advocates of reparations like
tallahassee coats suggest that paying
reparations wouldn't solve any of the
problems it mostly be a symbolic move
well the symbolism is again what the
great-great-great great-great
grandchildren of people who did not
enslave anybody paying a great-great
great-great-great grandchildren of
people who may have been slaves or who
may not have been in America at all what
is that about what that's about is
dividing America it's about suggesting
that slavery is not a blot on America's
past it is the heart of America's past
right that is the idea here and this is
why you see the left also refusing to
separate off from the black lives matter
organization now again we could all find
agreement we could all find agreement on
all the stuff slavery evil Jim Crow evil
systems of discrimination that you can
name and point out now like
systems evil we were all on the same
page we all want to fight that stuff but
the goal here is that again the
underlying narrative is about much more
than that it's about how America itself
is unchangeably unbridgeable evil
unchangeably and unbridgeable be wrong
and this is why you see so many members
left defending the black lives matter
organization when they don't even have
to now let's be clear about this the
black lives matter organization is not
the same as the slogan black lives
matter the black lives matter
organization is a radical Marxist
organization the people who organized
black lives matter are openly stated
Marxists and so it is no surprise when
the black lives matter organizer calls
Trump the terrorists in chief on CNN
here's one of the black lives matter
organizers talking about all this Donald
Trump is the embodiment of white
supremacist terrorism when he is you
know
tweeting videos of people throwing up
white power and really entrenching
himself within the white terrorist
movement you know for him again to call
anything hate is really the height of
hypocrisy and you know we need as a
country to be willing to point to him
and say that he is actually the
terrorist in chief okay milena Abdul by
the way let's just be clear about this
milena Abdullah suggested I'm a member
of the KKK when I visited Cal State Los
Angeles she suggested that I was a white
supremacist everybody is a white
supremacist in the view of of milena
Abdullah and by the way she
she also happens to be a far-left
neo-marxist okay this that is not a big
surprise it is not a surprise at all in
fact and this is the so it is worth
mentioning here that the black lives
matter organization is not the same as
the point black lives matter and that
it's not the same thing at all but this
has been swallowed hook line & sinker by
the media specifically because they
actually agreed with a lot of the
critiques of black lives matter or as an
organization not just the flow ghen of
the organization that America is a
deeply systemically evil place and again
everything is justified in the name of
this war everything is justified in the
name of this war even the principles as
supposedly good liberal people believe
go completely out the window immediately
if you're fighting a war
and that's how you have bizarre tape of
of protesters cross-dressing
twerking in front of cops in New York
City and
protesters were not of color apparently
screaming at cops that they are black
half of you don't even have a college
education intent here that these are
protesting protesters screaming at cops
they don't have college education okay
so you want to talk about classism you
want to talk about bigotry how about the
how about the bizarre notion that you
get to scream at police officers for not
having a college education and calling
black officers black Judas's but
anything is justified in the name of
ripping down the system because after
all that black cop who may have suffered
more racism than you have because what
are you a privileged kid who went to NYU
or something and now you get the
privilege of dancing around in a skirt
on the public streets of Manhattan in
front of him as it as presumably a
biological male in front of I mean that
this is like a pretty free world for you
in other words it doesn't seem like you
are suffering the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune here he gets a shout
at that black cop I'm sure has suffered
much more than you have in your young
life about how he doesn't have a college
education and is a black Judas
everything is justified when you're
attacking the system everything is
justified when you're attempting to tear
down the system and here's the thing
again this is the dominant culture all
will be made to kneel before it all will
be made to kneel before it Prince Harry
will be made to kneel before it Prince
Harry was forced into a hostage video
apparently by his wife Megan Markel
probably the most privileged person on
planet earth Prince Harry is gonna
lecture us all on systemic racism
because this is the this is the culture
right you are you are in the cultural
minority if you believe that America is
a good place and that the West is worthy
of Defense if you believe that American
system is good and it's created
prosperity and freedom for not just
millions but billions of people around
the earth this puts you in a bad place
if you believe Western civilization has
values that are worthy of emulation and
teaching this means you are bad and you
are racist so you will kneel before Zod
and you will accept the fact that you
are actually part of the system itself
here's Prince Harry doing exactly that
my wife said recently though our
generation and the ones before us
haven't done enough to wipe the wrongs
of the past I - I'm sorry sorry that we
haven't got the world to the place that
you deserve it
institutional racism has no place in our
societies yet it is still endemic
unconscious bias must be acknowledged
without blame to create a better world
for all of you I want you to know that
we are committed to being part of the
solution
what really you are you're like you were
you want to talk about Ches systems by
the way that dude is literally rich
because he was born that way
his entire family history is he is he's
a prince okay don't lecture me on
American tastes systems when you are a
prince also I'm just going to point out
here that if you think that Prince Harry
has any leg to stand on lecturing the
rest of us on how Western civilization
is bad you just got another thing coming
now in a second we're gonna get you know
there are real problems on planet Earth
well we're shouting at each other over
pronouns and pretending that America's
police are endemic ly violent and racist
and brutal there are actual real
problems in the world there are real
problems in America and abroad and it
turns out that the quote unquote
solutions that are being brought by the
post American Americans suck these
solutions are not solutions at all they
exacerbate all of the problems they
purport to be alleviating we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you need to be on
top of your data if you are a if you are
a small business owner today or a big
business owner today you need to be on
top of your data you cannot afford to be
running behind
what you need is NetSuite by Oracle it's
the world's number one cloud business
system finance HR inventory e-commerce
everything you need all in one place to
save time money and headaches whether
you're doing a million or hundreds of
millions in sales NetSuite will give you
visibility and control so you can manage
every penny with precision turn over
20,000 companies who trust NetSuite to
go faster with confidence NetSuite has
surveyed hundreds of business leaders
assembled the PlayBook of the top
strategies they are using as America
reopens for business received your free
guide seven actions businesses need to
take right now schedule your free
product store at NetSuite calm slash
Schapiro get that free guide schedule
your free product tour right now and
NetSuite comm slash Schapiro that is
NetSuite comm slash apparel go check
them out right now
NetSuite dot-com slash Schapiro again
you're a business owner you can't afford
to not be up on your data your data is
what is going to allow you to continue
to thrive in a very challenging business
environment make sure that all of your
doesn't your business systems are
integrated with NetSuite NetSuite comm
so that should be R to get your free
guide and your free products to our
right this very instant already in just
a second we're gonna get to another
indicator that nobody is talking about
solutions because they don't actually
give a crap about solutions this is all
about tearing down that rotten house
from the foundation as that New York
Times fee suggests but if you're not
already a daily Y remember you should
consider getting a readers past a daily
wire.com it's a great value for only 3
bucks a month when you sign up you get
that first month for only 99 cents
you'll also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials like my brand new editorial
which is all about the the problem with
new definition of racism and anti-racism
it's really worth the read plus we have
all sorts of articles with uh I have
another one over there about how the
Obama administration shattered the rule
of law there's plenty of stuff to read
plenty of stuff to do get a reader's
pass right now at daily wire com sign up
for just a dollar meanwhile as I've
mentioned you want to order something
for yourself like give yourself
something to look forward to over the
next three weeks go order pre-order my
book how to destroy America in three
easy steps
at daily wire.com at slash pen it is I
think the most important book in the
country where it will be released I
think it I think you're gonna find it
incredibly useful I think you should
find it inspiring because it really is
about how America is all the things that
it was cracked up to be
we didn't always live up to all of our
commitments in the founding documents
but America is the greatest country on
the face of the earth
it is a ringing endorsement of America
and a reminder of how to fight back
against the leftist narrative that has
taken over the country the
disintegration is narrative that's
tearing us apart right now it comes out
July 21st it already is on the
bestseller charts over at Amazon three
weeks early go check it out right now
over at Daley wire.com slash Ben go
check it out right now you're listening
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the policies I keep saying
that policies that are being pushed by
the disintegration is left policies that
suggest that we get rid of all cops
these are not about alleviating problems
the problems are not there to be solved
the systems must be taken down so the
push of cuts to police is the most
counterproductive thing pretty much ever
the notion that you're just gonna cut
the police this has been pushed the
defund the police movement is being
pushed by the New York Times it's being
pushed by colonists all over the left
wing he suggestion is the police are bad
the police are useless the police are
unnecessary bill de blasio
idiot communist mayor of New York he
gave a statement yesterday he said it's
time to cut the police budget in New
York by a billion dollars because young
people need to be reached now police
need to be reached send a social worker
to a shooting it's time the time has
come social workers to shootings by the
way worthy of note over a hundred people
have been shot in the past couple of
weeks in New York the violent crime rate
is rising rapidly here is Bill DeBlasio
being a fool our young people need to be
reached they don't need to be policed
they need to be reached and supported
and nurtured and that's what we're doing
not only a billion dollars you're
talking about another half billion bound
that to create recreation centers places
young people can go that are positive to
create broadband access for young people
in public housing we've got to do a lot
of things differently if we're going to
change the reality for so many Oh
internet porn and midnight basketball
that's probably gonna solve all this
stuff Internet broadband internet access
in midnight basketball we never tried
this stuff back in 99 back in the 1990s
this was Bill Clinton's big initiative
midnight basketball to make sure that
people have a place to go at night to do
something that was not crime it was not
actually effective you know his
effective putting cops on the streets
the fact is right now in Chicago 18
people were killed 47 wounded and drive
and walk by shootings last weekend alone
New York City's homicide rate is at a
five-year high the number of shooting
victims is up 42% through June 21st
compared with the same period in 2019
the number of shootings in the first
three weeks of June was over twice that
of the same period in 2019 making this
June the city is blood the city's
bloodiest in nearly a quarter century
according to the New York Times
Milwaukee's homicides have increased 132
percent it's perfectly obvious what is
going on you cut the cops or threatened
to cut the cops you threatened to
prosecute every
who does his job they are not going to
police and the result is going to be
more dead people but this is the whole
thing it's not about solving one of the
problems on the surface it's about
solving the systemic problem and the
systemic problems means you should let
the problems on the surface fester
because after all that just exposes the
corruption of the system what you don't
want if you're a member of the
post-american left what you don't want
is for the American system to be upheld
because you've fixed all the boo-boos
right you don't want to shore up that
house you don't want to fix the picture
frame in that house that is rotting
foundations you want to Dyna make the
thing you want it to come down about
your ears now the problems that
supposedly plague America but should be
very clear about this the problems that
supposedly plague Americans the the
freedoms that we are having ripped away
from us a brutal police the brutal
American system rural inequality hey
China just took over Hong Kong there are
actual problems on planet earth China
just subjected over 7 million people to
abject communist tyranny that is what
hung that's what's happening in Hong
Kong according to CNN Hong Kong was
facing up to a new reality on Wednesday
after china's central government imposed
a sweeping national security law late
the night before that critics say
stripped at the city of autonomy and
precious civil and social freedoms and
cements Beijing's authoritarian rule
over the territory at least 370 people
were arrested Wednesday including 10 on
suspicion of violating the national
security law among those was a 15 year
old girl
so they've there now arresting everybody
who flies a flag if you fire a freedom
flag in Hong Kong they will arrest you
according to The Wall Street Journal
they say China's decision to impose its
national security law on Hong Kong is a
seismic event that goes well beyond the
sad fate of it 7.5 million people the
illegal takeover shows that Beijing's
communist rulers are willing to violate
their international commitments with
impunity as they spread their
authoritarian model we say this with
regret because we were among those who
helped amid China's reform era in the
80s hoped that the Middle Kingdom could
be drawn into a world of peaceful global
norms Hong Kong was a lesson for Beijing
to learn from now those hopes are
crushed China's communist legislature
has imposed the national security law
that ends Hong Kong's one country two
system its governance I've suggested by
the way that anybody who wants to get
out and live a life of freedom should be
allowed citizenship in the United States
when we are looking at right now is the
complete subjugation of a once free
people to tyranny but don't worry the
real problem in America is obvious
policing it's obviously racist police
shootings again grand total 15 unarmed
black people were shot in 2019 according
to the Washington Post database of such
shootings 15 in a country of 42 million
black people but we were being told by
our intellectual and moral betters
people who will tell our children that
were bad human beings we're being told
that we are racist for pointing out
facts like this or for suggesting that
America system is actually free an
America system is actually prosperous
the same people who are lecturing us on
black lives matter in the NBA the LeBron
Jameses of the world are chiding members
of their own of their own organizations
for speaking out on behalf of Hong
Kong's freedom don't tell me that
there's a lot of moral courage to that
you take the check from China and then
you say a very very popular thing among
your woke base in the United States that
doesn't sound a lot like moral courage
it sounds mainly like you're the
dominant culture in the United States
when it comes to politics then that that
is the the message that takes moral
courage is the message that America is
filled with flawed people that America
is filled with sinful people just like
every civilization and that is our job
to find those flaws and find those sins
and try to extirpate those it is our job
to find racism learn where it exists and
try to extirpate it that when you find a
racist law or racist policy we try to
extirpate it but an america system is
free an america system has been driven
by the principles of the Declaration
those principles are not principles that
can be alienated those are not
principles that are worthy of
abandonment those are principles that
are worthy of emulation of upholding ok
if America is not willing to defend
herself if instead America just turns
into a slow cultural role toward post
Americanism then we're done here
we're finished by the way there are a
couple Republicans in the Senate who
have proposed a bill to make Jim
Juneteenth a national holiday which I
support that's fine that's good that's
good I mean I've called for it I was one
of the people on Twitter openly calling
for it this year okay that is a good
thing they also want to get rid of
Columbus Day at the same time which of
course completely caves to the leftist
perception of America as rooted in
fundamental Western evil and cruelty and
that is not that is not a culture that
can survive a culture that apologizes
for its own existence I mean American
culture not any racial culture American
culture any any country that refused
to stand for its own existence and point
and stand for its own principles and
recognize its own flaws in a nuanced way
while standing for those principles any
country that refuses to do that cannot
survive and I think that's the point I
think that a lot of people in the
dominant culture not the subculture
anymore the dominant culture who believe
that America should not survive as
currently constituted alrighty we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
have yourself a July 4th weekend where
we actually celebrate the fact that this
is in fact the greatest nation in the
history of the world we may have
forgotten that of late but it is no less
true for us having forgotten us for us
having forgotten it this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
produced by Colton Haas executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling assistant director Pavel why
douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback in media operated by
nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam Simons audio is
mixed by Mike Rowe Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to Andrew Kleber show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
Andrew Clayton
[Music]